This video is an ad for Seriously.
I don't know, do you ever wake up and feel like you do the same thing over and over again,
Like nothing changes?
Like, what are you saying right now?
I can't believe that we keep doing this all the time!
I just need to find myself.
I don't know.
Well it's the same thing over and over again!
No!
It's- *Sigh*
I'm living a loop.
Don't do this right now.
*arguing*
Don't go!
I'm going and I'm gone!
What changed?
I don't know, it's just
The level got harder,
The game seemed to be working against me,
You're feeling something and I need to help.
I just feel like a noob person, you know?
You look like a noob person
I went on a journey, and I found this new game that came out today.
If anyone were to click the link in the description below,
And download the game, they'd be an amazing person.
Best fiends,
Forever.
Who am I?
This is a bandage.
*Arguing*
It's something different, like a new game.
Seriously?
Yeah, they made the game.
What?
hmm?
We hope you enjoyed this video,
There are other trailers made by your other favorite youtubers, in the description below.
And download "Best Fiends Forever" for free, today.
Tell us which trailer was your favorite by voting through the like button.